There's a lot of rumors about the Apple logo and why the company is named Apple.
For example, a popular misconception...
...is that the logo is a representation of the forbidden fruit mentioned in the Bible.
The truth, however, is far more unexceptional.
Both Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak have said...
...that the name Apple was randomly chosen because of its simplicity,...
...and as they couldn't come up with a better name.
At the time, personal computers were not that common,...
...so they wanted a name that was easy to understand and not intimidating to the average person.
The logo was also chosen because of its simplicity.
At the very beginning though,...
...they actually used a logo featuring Isaac Newton sitting under an apple tree,...
...but this was changed because it would be unrecognizable in small print.
When they changed the logo to the current design,...
...they considered using a logo with or without the bite,...
...but, in the end, the logo with the bite was chosen...
...to make smaller versions indistinguishable from a cherry.